alles klar herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute mit max und es ist
eigentlich alles wie sonst wie immer
oder ja wer sind sie der name is talking
bereit ist meinen don't often vor
einigen tagen wollte dass sie passiert
was ich euch gleich zeigen werde
und es ist krass und deswegen heute hier
ja hier ist es geht sagt nein aber ich
hätte lust mal wieder zu zeigen wie sehr
sie dachte sie wären erst jetzt hat
jetzt sollten habe ich immer ich würde
ich finde es gut ich hab nur gesagt okay
ja gut aber nie länger oder jetzt
hinziehen hinten sind sie auch wegen was
passiert dass leute ganz einfach google
ist auf mich und einige andere youtuber
in deutschland zugekommen und hat gesagt
wollt ihr handy spiele spielen und ich
aber eine stelle gesagt liebes google
team via eventuell gesehen habt ist in
einem kanal an das wort zockt enthalten
und dann habe ich mir gedacht ich habe
einen letztlich weil jetzt hofft dann
bin ich einfach noch es ist nämlich so
etwas geht erst mal wieder zeit die
spiel
die band sollte sarah megacool es geht
einfach darum dass man ein handy spiel
gespielt so anders als bei 91 prozent
aller anderen werbevideos da draußen ist
im kellerderby verfolgte man kann
einfach gucken ist eben nicht immer ein
spezielles zurückgehen sollen einfach
nur um den google places und zocken
spielen das gibt s doch klar deswegen
machen wir das jetzt heute eine jetzt
schlafe einträgen jetzt leben aber nutzt
heute vier spiele heute wahr oder falsch
werde das ist ein spiel bei dem sich
darum dreht das meine gegner eine art
trifft man hat quasi doppelt screen und
bekommt immer so gewisse sätze angezeigt
wie zb der himmel ist rot und dann geht
es darum wer als erstes in dem fall
falsch klickt oder wenn es darum geht es
ist eine richtig coole sau als als
sonderfall sichtlich legen wir los
der test wurde gespielt natürlich gingen
nicht verloren bisher gespiegelte
bildschirm und heute kann ich ja noch
bestrafen und zwar keinen durst und zu
bestrafen wir beide das gleiche noch ins
fitnessstudio und tritt hier muss im
fitnessstudio die hofmanns getragen
andré die optimalste gewinnst du dir
richtig getrennt in die maske zu tragen
gemacht und wir waren besser aber ich
gehe und ich mit dem trainieren wir
machen best-of-three läutet spiel gehen
immer bis neun fragen der ersten fragen
geholt hat gewisse spielen zwei spiele
zu gewinnen
also kehrt erster punkt für max 2 dürfen
maximal
der online-vertrieb mich aber der
falsche zeugnis gibt es nicht halt dein
maul haltern ein buch mein gott jungen
mehr junge aber jetzt wo ich auf platz
fünf
wir haben genug zu sensibel zu 3 du hast
du stellst du schnell
juni erfolgt was ich mache da gar nichts
nein nein 1.0 in ein kalifat politikern
ist gesehen ja wo geklickt ja erreger 78
niedrige hürde frage panama stadt ist
die hauptstadt von katar watt max die
erste runde gewonnen alltag schnell
ich sehe mich nicht kennt wird er offen
was gehört der film natürlich denn für
euch alter schwede was habe ich da nur
gemacht egal ob die leute das zweite
runde let's go ich muss auch wohin so
steht jetzt schon fest dass ich mit der
affenmaske zweiter wurde schon ko für
mich los geht's schnell ja wohl jeder
fünfte leichtathletik richtig geraten
nein
möglich ist nur dass die leute von den
berg
jawohl 13 richtig 15 30
jawohl diese idee auf insgesamt bereiten
jetzt wird man punkt sechste vier junge
als haupt das auch schnell das
verständnis du christ paris frühstück
erweitert wissen lässt sich darauf schon
bald avantgarde geklickt und wer bern
hat die rolle finden die zum frühstück
bei bretten ich nicht gut deshalb
verknüpft je weiter ich hab ich habe das
nie 321 jungen darüber könnte ich jetzt
was geschafft nein
portugal ist die schriftsteller kann
jazzmusiker ist nicht 2016 und man kann
nicht mehr alte menschen im video da ich
habe mich ein bisschen zusammen dass die
vorstände jemand hilfe braucht dieses
gefühl ich mache das nicht weiter machst
du wachst aber max wusste machen wir die
leute die finale entscheidende runde
let's go richtig niemals von der 22
mannschaften zwölf menschen richtig
halte
was ich geplant hatte ich war schon ein
gekipptes brennt wird ja wohl 647 zu
viel wasser land auf ewig junge war 6 7
1 7 5 7
nein eigentlich verkaufen
pegasus heißt das dass die verdeckte
nicht trist habe jetzt sicher dass das
nicht der ok aber wisst ihr was leute
muss ob sie dann was stehen wenn es
vorliegt stellten der deswegen leute wie
jetzt für den studio trainiere nicht
siehst du dich ziele maßgebend findest
du dir auch ich werde sie angehalten die
ganze zeit über macht das mit dem handy
bisschen film und diese ist in europa
entwickelt es erfolge nicht sterben kann
man sich normalerweise eher weniger
das war es vom ersten video leute aus
dem google places werden auch einige
weitere kommen sechs an der zahl wie
jetzt war wieder eine krasse change mich
ausdenken und mag es einfach